here we go dave chappelle's story police
arrest suspect
an onstage attack of dave chappelle
rep calls incident unsettling this is a
usa today's story police have arrested a
suspect in on stage attack of de chapel
at the hollywood bowl in los angeles
tuesday during a netflix is a joke
festival and audience members stormed
the stage as chappelle 48 was exiting
the stage after his performance lunging
at him and tackle him to the ground
according to the press release from the
la police department chappelle refuses
to allow last night's incentive to
overshadow the magic of his historic
moment the comedians rep carla simpson
in a statement wednesday statement
wednesday
start the day smarter get all the news
you need in your inbox each morning dave
chappelle celebrated
four nights of comedy and music setting
record-breaking sales for a comedian at
the hollywood bowl sim said as
unfortunate and unsettling as the
incident was
chappelle went on with the show sim said
the venue security detained 23 year old
isaiah lee lapd officer rosario
cervantes told usa today wednesday uh
they arrested uh lee chappelle was not
injured lee was taken to the hospital
with minor injuries minor injuries have
you seen the guy's shoulder there's
nothing minor about that lee is being
held on thirty thousand dollar bond
according to the release matt what are
your thoughts about what happened here
well they roughed him up pretty good
didn't they um well of course everybody
immediately thinks this is uh you know
uh a result of what will smith did at
the oscars yeah he's just set a
precedent yeah you can attack comedians
on stage but do we have a motive for why
this guy went up there has he said what
his uh what why he wanted to attack dave
chappelle was it something dave
chappelle said or was he just trying to
so so
there was a there was a story first of
all this is not a good picture show the
video first so the audience can see what
happened most people have seen it
yeah this dude
yeah you see his arm yeah his arm is
bent the complete other way it was on
backwards yeah yeah can you show that
video first one so clearly security was
beefed up in a big way apparently it was
this jamie foxx that came to the rest
jamie foxx in a cowboy hat a bus a bus
bust an arm
here we go
look at the guy's arm do you see the
guy's arms his arm your arms facing like
the other way look at that his elbow is
out oh my god yeah that arm right so
you bring up a good point what was this
guy's motive yeah yeah we don't know
dude you know people are feeling very
comfortable
running up on celebrities days i'm not
sure if it's the will smith is if is it
art imitating life life imitating art
you're an actor this is something that
you probably deal with but this reminds
me of like the guy who felt
like he could
feel very comfortable talking [ __ ] to
mike tyson how'd that work out for that
guy right get the living crap kicked out
of him now there might be a lawsuit
pending
but it's there's almost like blurred
lines well you know that's a result of
social media that's just what i was
gonna say like all through the pandemic
all these musicians are playing guitar
inside their houses i'm like i don't
want to see inside your house i want
there to be a wall of mystery between me
and the artist you know what i mean and
social media has completely knocked that
down it used to be you know in the case
of like soap opera actors and whatnot if
you're i think uh
one of your last guests spoke a little
bit about this
um jason i think it was when you're in
somebody's living room every single day
on television the human body and brain
cannot distinguish between
a relative and a person on tv we haven't
evolved past that yet so it really feels
like you know that person because
they're in your home they're literally
versus being in a movie theater it's
very different right that's that's
watching tv and seeing a movie or two
different that was ethan sipley that
brought that up that's right that's
right um and so this may be you know
instagram and everybody doing things
from their homes and
you know uh celebrities being literally
reachable by through social media this
may have something to do with it or it
could just be this guy wanted you know
his five minutes of fame and who better
attacked and the best comedians alive i
don't know so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]
you